and then and then you get to hear them
speak before you decide and you got to
be naked to show yourself one of them's
got like wild accent another one and has
a deep what accent do you like Filipino
Filipino just kidding
[Laughter]
[Music]
no have you guys heard what about a show
called naked attraction yes that sounds
familiar netive traction Anthony Le all
right basically it's this [__] uh UK
or British TV show right that was that
aired like years ago like maybe like
2016 or some [__] like that and the
whole concept is going backwards with
the dating process usually when you
start dating somebody right you like uh
go on an app or whatever you meet them
up and you get to know them and then you
build up towards the idea of getting
them naked this one starts in Reverse
you see them naked first right and it's
like first you reveal like the bottom
half so you're like judging them by
their [__] penis with or their vagina
or whatever anything like that and and
then you reveal everything from the neck
down and you start making judgments and
you eliminate somebody based off your
preferences for that and then you see
their face and you get to learn about
them and then you get to choose uh and
then when you choose one person to go on
a date with before you get to choose out
of the final two you have to get naked
yourself and then show them so you're
just revealing all even though you don't
know [__] about each other damn wa
that's C and that's why they call it
naked attraction but it's kind of
hilarious so it got a lot of [__]
crazy they show dick in everything
really yeah and they full on show and
then it just came to HBO Max which is
why it's been like on as we were looking
up articles it was on hell of [__]
random headlines in articles dude UK
shows are crazier than the US way biger
cuz I think like our image in the US
about them is like they're prim and
proper but they're actually way
raunchier and their humor is crazier I
think we're just super sensitive to like
semi taboo Concepts in the US
everything's super sensitive sexualized
here but it's all like taboo over there
it's open and sexual like in commercials
they they're like nud and [__] like so
what I feel like we're like What do you
call it more purtin we are we are so
like they're Christian but different
kinds we're publicly purtin I feel like
for us we'll show public like we'll show
violence in movies and TV but we won't
show sex and for them it's the opposite
they'll show the N or whatever but they
won't show much violence and you wonder
why we have so much violence exactly
repress sexuality [__] exactly like we
hump a lot dry hump
Yeahs it is a [__] funny concept and
when you first see it cuz I watched the
first episode with Nina too and it was
just like immediately they're and
everything's [__] way better than
British accents you know what I mean
love Island I love love Island don't
they do it like yeah so that all right
we're going to go ahead and reveal the
bottom half and then you're just like
you're and it's always like you never
thought you going to see six dicks huh
and you're like oh holy [__] when you're
watching that are you kind of like you
know what I mean yeah are you covering
your eyes for you like going to get a
refill or you going to the bathroom and
at that point on the show do you feel
like you're you're creep for being hard
or should you be limp like everybody
else I'm definitely not hard when I'm
wait if you're on the show wait why
aren't you hard is something wrong with
your could you get a little chubbed up
if you're going to do the reveal is
something wrong with you like yeah no no
cuz like I feel like if I was on you're
a castmate right me is 100% about
temperature in the room hey the UK is
cold bro oh I'm going to be so small
then yeah dude yeah they don't have like
heaters and air conditioning for some
reason yeah I know so I'm wondering if I
was on the show okay I'm like all right
do I want to impress and be like girl
I'm a grower so let me show you the Peak
Performance or should I just be like I
don't want to like come off as a perve
on the show so like let me just let it
dangle but if I dangle I'm not showing
the you know it's like a my car has
great performance but they're judging it
by the look they're not letting me race
yeah all right let's let's let's put it
into a perspective that like we can
actually see some sort of like concept
of realism right let's imagine Joe's the
participant and he's the one who needs
to find a date and then you you first
get reveal that's not hard to imagine he
he recently went through that exactly so
six bottoms are now shown to you so
we're going to imagine I I would assume
they're all women right cuz there are
some uh you know B there's some tricky
ones I hope all right now uh from there
you're going to find different sizes
you're going to do find different uh
skin colors y you're going to find some
people that shave or don't shave you're
going to sign find some vaginas with
labia out or just super clean and tucked
and you're going to find some with like
tattoos or whatever which which thing
specifically are you first attracted to
and you have to eliminate you have to
you have to eliminate one in that round
and don't just say Le out immediately
yeah don't don't start with that like
what are you attracted to from just a
bottom down you don't know [__] about
personality just a [__] just a [__]
and down leg from the butt though this
is back he said Le out that was
literally a conversation topic on the
first episode understand I'm scared I'm
terrified as a as a [__] connoisseur I
have to say it's the inside that counts
a lot of people talk about the whole and
the Soul right so you want to [__] all
six
sometimes when you look at the vaginas
you go oh that's a nice looking vagina
right and you go inside you're
like it's not that good it's not that
good it's like graly in
here gra it's some what happen right and
then sometimes you're like oo phly
cheese steak and then you go and you're
like what the hell is in the
mechanical what what's happening so true
so you can never really judge a book by
it's covered no but aesthetically what I
typically like are uh pink ones oh
yeah I like pink ones okay pubes or no
pubes no pubes tattoo or no tattoo
around that area depends on what kind
but I don't like a tattoo thick or not
thick oh but what if it's a tattoo of a
dick no okay interes I actually know but
if it's like some girls got like a
little Cherry right here or like
something cute but then some girls got a
demon and then the the [__] is the you
know and then that's crazy that's too
much so shave metal it's metal shave
pink with a little cherry on the side
all right so Joe really likes that one
like a little I'm bad but it's a cute
you
know yeah I
the oh I would tell you a a yucky that I
don't like piercing on the [__] Okay
cool so no clip Pierce agree or disagree
whatever it's not sexy to me okay this
is mine all right so so now we move up
we already know that we've eliminated
the demon vagina or piing or anything
like that okay or or it's too hairy so
we already eliminated something of that
category right smooth [__] and then we
move up right and now we see uh from the
neck down no stomach okay so not fat
well fat is relative right but no ham
like I don't want to look like two
hamburger buns all right no folded no
folded belly all right we're talking
about giant nipples we're talking about
no small nipples we're talking about
nipples as big as your head I don't mind
big areolas actually you don't mind
bigger what if they're bigger than your
head that's too big but that means she
has a big old boobies yeah we're talking
about hopefully fake breasts real
breasts small breasts I like the I like
the real droop because uh fake breasts
to me look weird correct agreed agreed
like they're sexy but then there's
something cheap about the look where
it's like to sexualized to where it's
like you know how
like it's almost like oh you're a
professional hooker dude and it's like
watching this [__]
bounce yeah it doesn't [__] Bounce It
doesn't [__] mounce it looks kind of
hard yeah it's made the same [__] give
us a cup
size I don't know I don't know cup Siz
but no shame nice C's the D's I guess
that cleaned it up yeah I don't
know okay now we reveal so so we took
the fake tits out with a hard n non we
took care you took some A's and B's out
if if I wasn't going to be be in trouble
I'd be like can I do a smell test cuz
that's a big thing I was thinking about
that too now we're going to a too high
of a rating I was thinking about that
too there's so have you ever been around
a hot girl and you smell you're like why
do you smell like a locker room yep and
she's like cuz I [__] all the football
players I'm like don't say that please
don't tell me that I wish you didn't
tell me that all right now now it
reveals the rest okay and we've got
every single type we've got people with
like uh different hair colors different
hairstyles maybe like half shaven head
or like you know just yeah I like a lot
of hair we got glasses we've got [__]
cleft lip we got everything girl wow
they do that huh that's cool cleft lip
maybe braces I don't know I'm just
saying that she might give a good blow
variety huge variety you don't know
that's the whole point you don't know
personality can I have them all no [__]
you got to pick dude that's not life
right okay so now you've got the whole
package okay now we know from the bottom
down we want pink we want like a small
on bad tattoo no no I I said I don't
mind it's already there it's a cherry
it's a cherry cherry it's a little
cherry on the side no demon right and
she's clean shaving all right and then
we move up no fake breast no fold over
tummy you don't mind giant nipples I
like athletic giant huge 6in areolas I
like athletic boom
Ariel is bigger than your whole [__]
head hey from B to Z I'm down with that
yeah yeah even a I thought you said c to
D no that's just [__] okay now we're
moving up to the head D what's what's up
there a cute face that's fair I like a
cute face is there some areola
creeping this like top of the neck dude
covered into the chin this area covered
into the chin the rest of the ariela the
last I saw uh
one I saw a very volumptuous booby video
sure of course because there is a there
is a genre of massive tits right massive
and the girls aren't that they're not
they're more like curvy I don't have a
solid state drive I can't they're so big
that when you have a POV of them and
you're doing it their titties are
slapping their own chin yeah and that is
so huge it's a hard life to live is that
what you're trying to paint the picture
of but you need like a GeForce [__]
GTX looking 489 like hard like graphics
card to [__] pull that that's a lot
yeah yeah I don't have the kind of
processing power to handle that kind of
[__] you know I have to look at my own
wife's boobs I feel like dating is more
than just watching someone naked first
cuz it's just immediately thinking about
sex yeah amen but that's the point of
the show and then in the Las thing now
you've chosen two people fall in this
category of like what is like no you
want the [__] them both then and then
you get to hear them speak before you
decide and you got to be naked to show
yourself one of them's got [__] like
wild accent another one [__] has a
deep voice what accent do you like
Filipino
Philipino
kid I was
trying you're trying to underpant pitch
and he's like I like a [__] who's like
from way way way
East real south dark tan woman dark tan
woman dark tan woman below the equator
uhhuh no no one that looks like Hannah
cut the video Northern sounding wait so
what happens at this point and then and
then you I I have to get naked and then
see if she accepts oh that's what
happens wait does she see me back they
don't it doesn't work they don't see her
they don't see no they see they see him
so now these two the last two standing
our butt naked right and then he goes
and gets naked and then and then the
funny thing is the while he's getting
naked the host asks them what they think
of each other's bodies the two girls or
two guys and that's [__] funny who
what do they usually say what's the
conversation the H nak one guy who's
clearly not as like attractive or
whatever is kind of like yeah you know
in the first epod I only watched one
episode but in the first episode the guy
who was last who was like a lot more
like you know Stellar in a certain way
was also an ampute so he had like a you
know a bionic leg or what fake leg thing
right I like bionic yeah and then the
other guy who was in the final was like
like a rounder like average man type
like Dad b style so yeah the dad B Style
guy is like well you know I wouldn't
mind it and obviously the other guy had
a huge dick too and this guy was like a
very very average he's like I would mind
is uh some something nice I forget what
he
says which guy the guy with the missing
leg SI and then this guy who obviously
had nothing to jock physically of this
guy was like well I wouldn't mind his
other leg
funny [__] clever and he hella
deserved the win did he get the win he
did she comes back she's butt naked now
they're looking at each other and then
it's like what do you think her it's
like wow you know it's very beautiful
body and you're just judging bodies the
most that's so strange who did she pick
did she pick the guy with the big dick
but no Lake yes and we're looking at V
oh we are yeah yeah they're showing
everything but but the the thing they
need to do is they need to bend over
they don't know cuz they they just stand
like this and then they're like oh
that's a nice [__] what they need to do
is go contestants thank you bam finally
that's what needs to happen the director
like they need to put their leg on top
of their head yes the director the
director dropped the [__] ball and
we'll say it we'll say it on JK news
it's kind of amate hour but it's okay
what they need to do is you know at the
doctor's office they got the wax paper
just okay you H you don't have anything
you just have a hole and then you go in
put it in one the next one the next one
and you go which [__] felt the best to
you exactly and then you could be like I
like two but three really would a
constra she does her key goals and then
see Japanese game shows are way better
cuz that's what they do on japanes oh
yeah they do and then they're like cool
you match with this chick who's bigger
than a house and then you're just
like bigger can I go again oh no what
the [__] did I do oh no I f up so bad oh
I [__] up so
bad no I would I would have been like I
want to win the good prize I think I
lost I CH my mind I they say I won but I
think I didn't win I think I lost I
think I got set
up I got the biggest one but it's not
the biggest
prize if her [__] was the best though
I'd keep it good hey it's the inside
back count inside that
count
[Music]